this is no longer just a set of weird
ideas that individuals scattered across
the country believe in this is a
movement now
one of the most noted aspects of the Ron
Paul phenomenon is how young excuse is a
76 year old you know super culturally
conservative obstetrician from Texas you
know been in Congress for 30 years and
he has generated this youth momentum
that's almost unprecedented in modern
American politics I found in researching
my book that many many Ron Paul fans
don't necessarily agree with or even
totally understand everything Ron Paul
has to say but they do know that this
guy is telling them the truth as he sees
it and that's something they react to
very warmly you know after a lifetime of
feeling lied to by every politician they
see and rightly feeling lied to by every
politician they see here's a guy who
they know is speaking the truth as he
sees it this is a guy who was really
incredibly daring I mean he's willing to
say in front of a Republican debate
audience that it's ridiculous to think
that heroin needs to be illegal and that
have a warrant illegal we'd all be doing
heroin how many people here would use
heroin food illegal Ron Paul is a guy
who was willing to say to a Republican
crowd the day before he has to win an
extremely important straw poll in Ames
Iowa that we need to apply the Golden
Rule to our understanding of foreign
policy and see that there are probably
lots of reasons why Iran thinks it makes
perfect sense that it should have a
nuclear weapon and that there's no
reason that we need to go to war over
the notion that one more country might
have a nuclear weapon maybe we ought to
consider a golden rule in foreign policy
don't do to other nations
we don't do times young people really
are attracted to this sort of boldness
and daring and he's the only politician
willing to say these things because
every other politician is just sort of
defending some small portion of the
status quo he has a full-fledged
political philosophy to sell he's been
selling it for decades and he's not
going to you know chip away at it just
for the sake of electoral advantage I've
been watching Ron Paul in the Ron Paul
phenomenon since 1988 I first saw him
speak to a crowd at a big state school
the university of florida in january
1988 when he was running for president
with the libertarian party and just a
few weeks ago I saw him speak at another
huge state school UCLA here in LA the
differences were staggering in 1988 Ron
Paul was speaking to around a hundred
kids who were just sort of looking into
this weird curiosity in 2012 Ron Paul is
speaking to 7,000 kids who aren't really
there to learn they are there to cheer
they know all this stuff already when
Ron Paul says the name Ben Bernanke
7,000 kids are booing when Ron Paul
mentions the National Defense
Authorization Act 7,000 kids are booing
they are there to express their beliefs
to gather in fellowship to sort of
cement the idea that it this is no
longer just a set of weird ideas that
individual scattered across the country
believe in this is a movement now